this [ __ ] he's just like come on bro
let's go you had asked me back in the
day to pull up to a 50 guy game man i
would have been like oh
but i knew some dudes in new york that
would be on that where they would like
be like oh yeah you know like friday
like me and like 12 we're going to run a
train we got a hotel room in this [ __ ]
who's down to get ran through it's like
50 bucks each and i would overhear these
comments i but i never really went for
it so i'm kind of casual yeah if nothing
shocks me anymore being around this guy
yeah cause like i just don't know if i
can get into it you know what i'm saying
i'm desensitized to sex now
it's like it's not like
sacred because of adam or because of
because of adam
the stories the [ __ ] that i see now like
the doing the patreons would make you
just lose hope and all that he saw a
woman who was as tall as me put her
whole hand in her butthole and it was
bleeding see you keep saying i didn't
see blood
and it was bleeding this is on camera
yes that was on the picture wait the
chick fisted herself she put her hand up
her ass
oh my god kevin's such horny vibes dude
i know
he would love hey instead of the dream
champs
and you can watch all the boys at work
yeah no
i just i'm just like yo
that would be just like a very
interesting thing to witness i've seen
we've seen a we've seen a was there lube
involved i think she did she worked with
a little kid
oh yeah somebody that this we should be
like look let me show you a trick i can
do without like any prep
this took real skill we seen a girl come
she made herself sport all over the
floor in like three seconds oh that's
piss
well she peed yeah no that's definitely
piss yo you you
i mean you probably made a girl squirt
in your life for sure
many the next minute the next day got it
the next day you got pissy bed sheets it
smells like piss yeah i mean hey
i had uh adriana chick did that to my
couch yeah she [ __ ] she squirted all
over the couch and then afterwards when
she left i'm like well now i got a wet
couch the [ __ ] am i gonna do with this
yeah when you sleep on that [ __ ]
at my former apartment yeah oh wow
jesus yeah squirt is definitely urine
and you oh and it feels good like at the
time and then the next morning you wake
up and you're like
especially if you have kids you're like
yo why does it smell like
oh
you got to wash the sheets you don't
want your kid finding your squirt puddle
it's a squirt puddle or the
[ __ ] that's why when you like
like
man mattresses is [ __ ] disgusting you
know